your son i don't want to embarrass your
son but he's grown up into
one of the coolest handsomest guys i've
ever seen in my life it's
comical uh just uh how good looking and
nice and suave he is
uh does does julian know the show does
he watch the show or was that weird for
him like i can't watch a show that my
mom's on
yeah we haven't talked about wise
i just know that he hasn't seen every
episode
i mean no no i know for a while in
school people were watching it and he
kind of felt like he had
to so that he could participate in what
everyone else was
watching and he did really think
that everybody else was very funny on
the show
and then that's a classic kid just like
everyone else is funny that's classic
that and that is true i think for all of
us i'm not sure i can't i don't know but
i know that he
you know he would say but and you're
funny too
he's like thanks hey don't be too sad
when uh when he was growing up can i
just i have to say something
true and nice he was able to uh come to
the reunion okay uh other
attempt you know not in the audience
right and all that really said covet
safe
and afterward uh he came up to me and he
just said
i don't know this is awkward or
inappropriate
can i say that i'm really proud of you
oh
that's so nice yes that was one of the
very emotional things that happened to
me
that's not part of it but you know just
like
oh it was really nice of him yeah
that's that's a beautiful moment yeah
not because he saw the show and went god
she's good
yeah but i think you know that's okay
too
you i mean he grew up kind of on that
set in the early years you would bring
him to the set
and he got a little confused like he i
know that he really was obsessed with
jen
anderson yeah no no he'd fly into her
lap
like as if well she's a love bug
and you know and that made sense and i
was always glad for
anyone that julian felt love for and
felt
from but then at home like she'd be on
tv and he'd go
mommy
that's got to be a little scarring maybe
i guess i remember it yeah for a reason
not scarring but just sort of
is this well you know i'm kind of
analytical so i'm like is this wishful
thinking
or do they have some kind of higher
soul connection that i don't have with
him
well i'm happy for both of them yeah